over the last couple months actually
more like a year and a half I've been
really head down building Vayner media
my agency taking it from a 30 to 250%
agency that's very predicated on a bunch
of young people show them real quick
show
them young and one of the things that
really excite me is the mentorship that
I've been able to do and I've been using
an analogy lately because I have so many
25 26 32-year-old managers about how to
handle the pressure because the pressure
is really the issue that if you're allow
the pressure I love it he photo vomit
yeah amazing uh the pressure is really
the issue always the issue and so I've
used this analogy lately that's really
been working and so I figured I'd just
share it with more people cuz if they
can get some value out of it it's kind
of what I want to do so the analogy is
this I consider pressure when you're
managing to be a process of your bucket
now some people have small buckets those
are managers that ultimately don't
become managers and some people have
huge buckets my bucket's probably like
the ocean right but as your bucket goes
up it is
to speak to the people above you
parallel to you and Below you to empty
the bucket emptying the bucket as a
manager is the game not allowing all the
pressure All The Angst that when when
you're disappointed with somebody but
not allowing that to overflow your
bucket that is the key so communication
getting it off your chest talking to the
people you're working with
emptying your bucket is the k